you know what it is smash that like
button
there are so many people out there right
now whose lives don't slap
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
hand them out jars of my own artisanal
mustard this is 100
stone ground artisanal mustard product
link in the description
let's go right now and find some people
that could really use a jar of mustard
obviously don't record this but we only
actually have one jar so we need to find
like a dude without a scar or like a
family we could give it to one of the
kids
if it's like a guy who's bleeding
youtube will demonetize it so
let's just try to find somebody who
looks like they need a little help but
not everything
you know all right bro get him he looks
like really homeless
yo what up bro listen it's your lucky
day fam
some people say it's christmas i call it
flavors we got artisanal mustard for you
this is my own company i started this
company as 13 years old
it's worth 150 million dollars right now
how does that sound
are you getting this can you get me in
him bro thanks dude you gotta [ __ ]
pay attention man the last time the
lighting was bad
are you steve will do it no i'm not you
want to buy a couple of jars of this
shout us out on insta twitter help build
our brand that's fine man
like a lot of people are doing [ __ ] i
don't even care about the clout you know
what i mean
smash that like button right now if you
want to end homelessness and what i'm
just saying right now is like
it's just i'm blessed to be at this
point in my life i'm 14 years old
and i own 12 companies look at the
sunset look how [ __ ] beautiful that
is
that's beautiful you know garyvee dude
bros it's like garyvee says
content is king but marketing is queen
take this muster bro i got you bro
always remember that [ __ ] content is
king or marketing is queen
i'm out
yo i think we did a lot of great work
today so smash that like button if you
want to end homelessness
and remember your brand shouldn't be
about what you have
it should be about what you give
[Music]